this is very exciting uh you were just
cast in a movie just I'm told this just
happened what days ago a movie with
Robert De Niro yeah uh and a lot of
other great people uh Catherine Heigl
right Diane Keaton and uh the kickers
that it films in my hometown
it's filming where's your hometown uh in
Connecticut okay so this is amazing to
me because that is everyone's dream that
you get cast in a movie say with someone
as as Mega famous as Robert De Niro and
then it's shot in your hometown or their
nightmare yeah but why would that be
your nightmare um well I moved away uh
to go to boarding school when I was
really young when I was like 12. right
so my room stayed the same since when I
was 12. I've got like yeah thanks so
you're assuming it is what it is which
is like a bunk bed
um like glow-in-the-dark stars like all
the dinosaur toys and I stay there once
or twice a year you know over Christmas
or whatever so uh I'm gonna live there
this summer I'm gonna sleep in the bunk
bed I really hope that De Niro comes
over and visits you at home right that
would be so great him in the bottom bunk
said it's a bunk bed yeah yeah he can
have tops or bottoms Robert if you're
watching I want you to know that's
what's going to be fun about the film
now is this is this my big thing that
I'm nervous about is you know I've tried
really hard because my folks and my
family lives on the east coast to kind
of not invite them to too much stuff
because you know Hollywood can be kind
of a tricky weird place yeah but now I
can't avoid it because uh you know it's
going to be in there yeah so I feel like
my mom's gonna like you know have to
drive me to work in the morning
a minivan yeah I'm like Mom like Bobby
De Niro's making fun of me drop me off a
block before
yeah he's gonna be dropped off by his
mom
I'm just curious if you're like me I
grew up outside Boston and I never saw a
celebrity growing up did you ever I mean
literally I don't think I saw a
celebrity until I was 18 or 19 years old
when was the first time you saw us my
first celebrity yeah I was not uh in New
England it was actually in England
um at herod's you know Harrods at
Department big department store yeah I
was like in maybe sixth grade I was
really young and uh this is actually a
funny story I bumped into uh
Scott Bakula
yeah Scott Scott Bakula from uh from
right from Quantum League a lot of great
stuff great actor yeah and he couldn't
have been nicer I mean I I didn't even
really I didn't know how to approach a
celebrity so I kind of said like hey
you're the guy from Quantum Leap which
if someone said that to me and by the
way people have said that to me you know
you're the guy from That 70s Show and
I'm not nearly been as nice as he was to
me he'll say like people say to me
you're that guy from Conan O'Brien right
who do you play yeah I'm chip Whitley I
play the part of Conan uh so I said
you're the guy from Quantum lead and he
said like uh yeah I guess his wife was
shopping or something so he really had
some down time and he really spent like
a while with me he autographed something
and then he said he'd been there's a
theater in my hometown so he performed
at that theater so he couldn't have been
nicer he wouldn't have been nicer and
about
uh nine months ago I saw him in Ralph's
this uh you know grocery store here in
LA and I thought I'm gonna blow this
guy's mind right like I mean what are
the odds that I met him and then I
actually became an actor right and was
on TV too and was in movies too so I
kind of went up to him and said like uh
hey Scott I know you don't remember the
first time that we met
um but my name's Topher and uh and he
goes hey thanks man I'm shopping
[Laughter]
have you ever seen That 70s Show because
that was that happened I'm the guy from
that I'm shot off yeah okay I'm shot
Spider-Man three two okay shopping
I don't want to hear about it I'm
shopping right I gotta I'm gonna start
saying that to people who come to me
even if I'm not shopping I'm just
walking down the street hey Connor hey
I'm shopping I'm your father Conan son
I'm shopping